let's get more on the tory leadership
race from a supporter of liz trust i'm
pleased to say we're joined by the
former northern ireland secretary
brandon lewis brenda lewis good morning
to you thank you very very much for
coming in good morning so
let's just pick up first of all on those
polls that we saw overnight a huge
boost for liz trust in the campaign but
david davis thinks that we can't trust
those polls because they're all a bit
different
well dave is right in the sense of any
poll is a snapshot in time and this is
quite a big poll of party members and it
builds on the work they did a couple of
weeks ago that gave it is a good lead as
well but the reality is there's only one
poll that counts and that's the one
where the members actually vote and
we'll get the results of that in
september so it's important for all of
us we've got to keep working
keep talking to members and this is
getting around the country talking to
members as well as the hustings and the
events we've got going on to secure
those votes for liz to become the next
leader of the conservative unionist
party and as a result the next prime
minister how damaging was that road back
on the regional papers do you think
i i don't think it was look what liz did
yesterday which was very clear we're not
taking that part of the policy forward
it's part of a bigger package obviously
she was talking about dealing with
whitehall waste which i think people do
want to see us uh deal with we've seen
with the rishis campaign as well he's
had like nine different things now where
he's flip-flopped around i'm pleased to
see he's now supporting the north island
protocol and i'm pleased to see he
believes in a lower tax economy although
i don't think we should be waiting seven
years for that at least wants to get on
with it as quickly as possible and put
more money in people's pockets in the
first seven weeks
let's have a look at what was said about
this idea because it was described as
willful misrepresentation
this is what was said a couple of days
ago
trust would introduce regional papers
tailoring pay to the cost of living
where civil servants actually work this
could save 8.8 billion pounds per year
potential savings and the system were to
be adopted for all public sector workers
in the long term so how did we
misrepresent that when we put that as
jacob rees-mogg was sitting there
yesterday and he defended it and then an
hour or so later it was entirely
scrapped well what was the
misrepresentation we saw some people in
other parts on the the other side of the
campaign arguing that this was about
reducing pay for the civil servants and
the public sector works who've done such
brilliant work over the last and it's
not about reducing no no it's never been
about that look what that's outlining is
if you were to extrapolate this out of
cross then yes you could see those kind
of savings but this was actually always
about look how you look at what you do
in new contracts and new people come
into the civil service but as i say
importantly this has been very clear as
she was yesterday pretty quickly after
that she's not taking this part of that
policy forward at all halfway to
defending it and i'm saying it was a
good idea the idea that someone getting
who's a nurse working in the south of
england could get paid more than a nurse
working up in the north you were very
close to saying that was a good idea
what the whole package was about
yesterday was dealing with whitehall
waste and actually making sure we're
spending this every penny the government
spends is taxpayers money we need to
make sure we spend that efficiently and
effectively
what was outlined there was what you
could save if you were doing this across
the board but that was never the case
and this was actually really clear about
this yesterday herself this was about
actually looking at what you could do
with new people coming into the civil
service but she's being we're not going
to do that we're not taking that part of
it forward what she wants to focus on
though is dealing with whitehall waste
as part of getting economic growth which
means we can actually reduce taxes put
more money in people's pockets and
deliver for people across the country
and of course importantly people talked
about this linked to leveling up the
best way we get leveling up is investing
across the country particularly in
education area liz has got experience of
and has got a very strong set of
policies to deliver on for people in the
future does it speak to questions around
liz truster's judgment that she'd even
put this policy forward and it it's not
like it's a brand new idea my
understanding is is one of liz truster's
ideas from about four years ago and a
time when people are going through a
many people feel like they're going
through a real terms pay cut we have a
cost of living crisis the idea that you
can be paid differently in different
parts of the country doing the same job
will not be a very good vote whenever
well as i say liz has been clear but
that's not something she's going to be
doing look what we have what we have
seen but she still put it she ran and
she's all put it forward and as i say
she's also been very one of the things
you've seen with liz trust both in her
jobs in government but actually over the
last few weeks as well through this
leadership campaign is somebody who's
looking at how do we improve our country
how do we grow our economy create more
jobs create more opportunity for people
improve education level up across the
country and she's somebody who even when
things are difficult will get on and get
things done she's done that as a foreign
secretary i've stood side by side with
her defending the people of northern
ireland against the pressure from the eu
she was resolute on that and we've seen
the northern ireland protocol bill go
through one of the things i think is
slightly odd that i see from uh
competitor camp if you like is they keep
flip-flopping around under like nine
different things at the moment and
particularly on the protocol where i've
seen them sort of argue against it and
now i've come and supported nine
different things
on tax on on on the economy um on the
northern protocol bill on china on a
whole range of things there are areas
where they've said one thing then done
another what has been clear released is
consistently issued somebody when she
outlines something that she wants to do
even when it's difficult again the
northern ireland protocol bill is
controversial it's been challenging with
the eu but she has been determined to do
the right things even when it's
difficult she will go out and have that
conversation and drive something forward
to deliver the right thing for the
people of the uk but all of you guys
flip-flopping around throwing things at
the wall and seeing which will stick i
mean over the weekend there was all this
talk about education reformer making
sure that every single student would get
who got a stars would get an interview
at oxbridge it seems to have quietly
been knocked down now that unions and uh
universities don't seem happy about it
so all of you are trying to throw
policies at the wall to see which ones
will stick aren't you some of them
sticking some of them down this one
obviously didn't well there's a couple
of things to say to that first of all
obviously during the leadership campaign
obviously the both the candidates are
out there talking about the kind of
things they would want to do as prime
minister liz has also been very open
about the fact we've got a manifesto
from 2019 to deliver so when she's
talking about the economic and the tax
benefits she wants to bring to people
into companies that's in the context of
delivering the manifesto but in the
context of where we are today with the
economic challenges we have but i think
the the education package that we
outlined at the weekend including the
university one is a really good one in
that it delivers on aspiration and says
to people if you're good enough you'll
have the opportunities that you want to
have you won't be restricted by where
you're from or your background and
actually i've seen the benefit of this
in my own constituency where the
improvement that we've seen in our
schools through academies and through
free schools has been utterly phenomenal
and transformational for students now
able to take advantage of the jobs that
coming through and that's what liz wants
to deliver on and that's what that
package of the weekend absolutely
outlines how useful to keep in the union
together is describe a nuclear surgeon
as an attention seeker who should be
ignored well i think actually keeping
the union together there's again an area
where liz trust has got huge credentials
and just on that particular issue i
think she i absolutely back her up on
this we had a yeah we had we had a
referee
in terms of looking at the referendum
and the independence or part of the
union for scotland we had a referendum
now we're all a few years older but it's
not been a generational change just yet
and that was always clear and the smp
were that that was a once in a
generation that decision has been made
what we should all be focused on
including the snp is how we improve the
lives of people in scotland they're
failing them on education i would argue
the health service and other areas of
the economy as well what liz wants to do
is make sure everybody across the uk and
every part of the uk gets better
education opportunities to take part in
a better and stronger economy in the
future let me get a thought from you on
the rwanda policy i think you'll have
seen the reporting this morning that the
the court has said that it cannot be
there can be no flights going until at
least november pretty patel home
secretary the moment says that she's
disappointed by that well let's trust
continue with that policy because we had
700 people crossing the channel
yesterday look yes i haven't seen the
details this morning yet actually but
look she will be continuing that policy
somebody's been in the immigration
ministry and spent a few years my life
in the home office in various jobs
dealing with border security i think it
is right that we are doing everything we
can to break the business model of the
those people are perpetrating modern
slavery people trafficking we've seen
reports even in the media as well about
already how it's having an impact for
some although we saw these record
numbers this week which i think
reinforce and remind us there's still
work to do and we've got to make sure
that we're delivering on that kind of
policy to break this business model of
the people traffickers that are putting
people's lives at risk it also means of
course the other side of this is when
people do come to this country and do it
through a legal rule we're able to give
them the support that they need to
integrate and be an important part in
our economy in our in our civilized you
know civil society in a way that they
want to be so illegal immigration
doesn't work because it perpetrates more
crime it puts lives at risk it means
that if people do get here they then
don't get the support that they need has
always been there aren't enough legal
routes will this trust expand legal
routes for people when they come back
actually i think and somebody as i say
is big immigration minister we have got
very clear legal routes for both asylum
seekers for refugees for people who want
to migrate to the uk we've got to focus
on making sure that they are there for
people who deliver on them but the best
way you do that is to be clear that you
have to take a legal route we are not
able we shouldn't be accepting illegal
routes into the country and we've got to
continue to crack down on that in every
way that we can okay brandon let's have
to leave it there thank you very much
for being with us good morning to you
thank you